[Music]
straight ahead on long crime daily
he
accused him of
essentially threatening him with a
hammer and you can hear in one audio
tape
rey
saying that i'm going to smash this
through your skull testimony continues
in the federal trial of the accused
sarah lawrence college cult leader and
what caused the heaven's gate mass
suicide these people who are laughing 24
or 48 hours later kill themselves with
bags dead over their heads a closer look
at the infamous cult plus the man
accused in the deadly waukesha parade
appears in court why the judge draws
parallels to another high-profile case
there is precedent for that as well in
waukesha county yes
and that of course is related to the
slenderman cases but first defendant
jesse smallett yells at the judge
moments after a sentence is handed down
i did not do this and i am not suicidal
and if anything happens to me when i go
in there i did not do it to myself we
take you inside the courtroom for the
heated exchange long prime daily
covering court cases from coast to coast
[Music]
everyone to law and crime daily i'm
brian buckmeyer along with terry austin
a reprimanding from the judge and
outburst from the defendant as a
sentence is handed down to the tv star
jessie smallette and terry austin has
been following this case from the very
beginning
in 2019 when smollett reported that he
was the victim of a hate crime two years
later he's given jail time restitution
and a hefty fine
all of this stems from a hoax attack in
2019 where smollett claimed he was
attacked by two men who poured bleach on
him tied a noose around his neck and
called him racial and homophobic slurs
later investigations found smolid
actually faked the attack in december a
jury found smollette guilty of making a
false report and disorderly conduct in a
sentencing hearing on thursdays mollet
was sentenced to 150 days of jail time
in the cook county jail 30 months of
felony probation more than a hundred and
twenty thousand dollars of prostitution
to the city of chicago plus a twenty
thousand dollar fine judge james lynn
said smollett was selfish arrogant
narcissistic for following through with
the scheme
there's some conjecture you did it for
the money
frankly i do not believe that you did it
for the money
you were making the evidence showed
close to two million dollars a year when
this happened i don't think money
motivated you at all
but the only thing i can find
is that you really craved the attention
and you wanted to get the attention
and you were so invested in issues of
social justice
and you knew that this was a sore spot
for everybody in this country and you
took some scabs off some healing wounds
and you ripped them apart for one reason
you wanted to make yourself more famous
and for a while it worked
everybody was talking about you the
lights are on you you were actually
throwing a national pity party for
yourself and why would you do such a
thing why would you i understand you
crave the attention so much but why
would you betray
something like social justice issues
which you care so much about
the only thing i can conclude is that is
and i acknowledge there are wonderful
sides to you they're very giving and
charitable and loving sides to you but
you have another side of you that is
profoundly arrogant and self selfish and
narcissistic
after that smollette had an outburst in
court repeating that he was not suicidal
i am not suicidal
okay i am not suicidal i am innocent and
i am not suicidal
if i did this then it means that i stuck
my fist in the fears of black americans
in this country for over 400 years and
the fears of the lgbtq community your
honor i respect you and i respect the
jury but i did not do this and i am not
suicidal and if anything happens to me
when i go in there i did not do it to
myself and you must all know that
i respect you your honor i respect your
decision
jail time
i am not suicidal okay
smollett was escorted out of the
courtroom holding his fist in the air he
is currently serving his time at the
cook county jail in chicago brian
joining us today is legal analyst dina
dahl dina a very impassioned sentencing
from the judge what do you think of the
judge's sentence and his final thoughts
on the case
you know it's a bit surprising that he
received jail time considering how much
good he had done before this but the
judge was really offended about you know
what this may mean for people who have
been are victims of hate crimes in the
future and the fact that he took the
stand and lied for hours and did it only
because the judge believed for attention
which you know the way he had his
outburst after the sentencing may have
also seemed a little bit of an attention
grabbing i don't know that and of some
people's views that may have um
validated what the judge said yeah now
terry smellet didn't have anything to
say before being sentenced he was
offered an opportunity to do so but he
had a lot to say afterwards your
reaction
you know what brian i think he declined
making a comment because he's thinking
about that appeal he doesn't want to say
anything that might adversely affect his
opportunity to win the appeal
but he should have expressed some
remorse and he had none he didn't give
any message to the actual hate crime
victims out there who now are going to
hesitate before they actually bring
claims and the judge mentioned that and
instead of saying anything he raised his
fists and complete defiance and he
basically was shouting out that he's not
suicidal and i believe he did that
because he's worried that something
could possibly happen to him when he's
in jail and he's basically threatening
the world saying look it's not going to
be my fault it's going to be your fault
and i didn't do this so you all are
putting me in a very dangerous position
i think once again he's thinking about
himself yeah well 150 days in cook
county jail along with 30 months of
probation and a number of fines and
surcharges and restitution afterwards
we'll see how this continues as we're
anticipating a potential appeal or at
least an uh request for an appeal and
this the case of jesse smollett
an accused killer lori valodebo's
extended stay in an idaho mental health
facility reached its 180-day mark this
week as questions loom about her
competency to stand trial this as a
clone hearing is held on friday after
sealed documents appeared in her online
portal known as the doomsday duel valo
dabo and her husband chad dabo are
charged with multiple counts of
conspiracy to commit murder and
first-degree murder for allegedly
killing valo's laurie valo dave bell's
children j.j and tyler and chad's first
wife tammy in june of last year valodeva
was committed to the idaho department of
health and welfare after she was deemed
incompetent to stand trial months later
her time there was extended by at least
180 days that deadline passed just this
week reports previously submitted to the
judge were then sealed and the judge did
so citing that the documents contained
information on valor day bell's mental
health and restorative treatment we will
bring you the latest developments out of
that hearing on the next episode of law
and crime daily
still ahead on law and crime daily what
caused nearly 40 people to commit mass
suicide an in-depth look at the heavens
gate cult but first why a waukesha
county judge looks for guidance from the
slenderman case as a trial date is set
for the man accused of the city's
christmas parade attack
[Music]
hi this is dan abrams with exciting news
for all of our law and crime followers
on youtube you can now get the live law
and crime network with youtube tv for
all of your daily live trial coverage
legal news expert analysis and original
true crime programs subscribe to youtube
tv today and then locate law and crime
in the channel guide and for only 1.99 a
month you can add the network to your
bundle
watch lawn crime every day with youtube
tv we put you in the jury box
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome back to law and crime daily a
trial date is set for the man accused of
ramming his suv into a christmas parade
in waukesha wisconsin six people were
killed and dozens more injured when
authorities say daryl brooks jr drove
his suv passed
prayed barricades he now faces 83 total
charges including six counts of homicide
and multiple counts of reckless
endangerment in a court appearance on
friday judge jennifer dureau heard from
both sides as the defense argues for a
change of venue saying it would be
difficult to find an unbiased jury in
waukesha county for such a highly
publicized case the prosecution argued
preemptive jury questionnaires may help
determine whether the trial needs to
change venues after that judge rowe
brought up another high profile case out
of waukesha county
we propose it may be extremely helpful
to send out jury questionnaires
very far in advance our ideas
try and screen as many people as we can
with the significant questions if
anybody's donated money if anybody
was at the parade if anybody knows
somebody who was injured at the parade
things like that there is precedent for
that as well in waukesha county yes um
and that of course is related to the
slender man cases
while i was not presiding over that case
i was fully aware and at times involved
in the planning and
um
during questionnaires were utilized
that was a case where everyone
expected it would take a week to impanel
that jury and it took a day
i think in large part due to the jury
questionnaires
brooks's month-long trial is now set to
begin on october third let's bring back
legal analyst dina dahl and co-host
terry ossin to discuss the change of
venue out of waukesha wisconsin now this
change of venue argument seems to have
two points move the trial or bring
jurors from outside the county so terry
what are the arguments for removing the
trial and where can they go in wisconsin
that they haven't heard about this case
well actually i think it would be better
to move the trial rather than bring in
jurors from another county i think it'd
be much easier and i do think they
should probably move it look you're not
going to find another county in the
state where they haven't heard about
this case but i think waukesha county
really is a little bit prejudiced
there's so much
publicity before the trial and not only
that i think that you know there's a
slogan now waukesha is strong and that
will affect everyone who lives there and
there's a memorial where the killings
took place so i think it might make
sense to move it do whatever you can to
give the defendant as much as they can
under the sixth amendment to a fair
trial yeah the other thing i can see as
well as there may be someone who at
least knows someone who's at the parade
or knows someone who knows someone
that's gonna be difficult as well deal
let's look on the other side though how
does bringing out of county jurors work
and does that make it more likely the
jury would be sequestered
yes the jury would be sequestered in
that situation what the judge would
decide in wisconsin is first the
determination would have to be made that
the change of venue is appropriate kind
of like what terry talked about you know
that
he would have to do it to um have a fair
trial without publicity or because there
were so many people at the parade
and also the fact that the jury would be
sequestered but instead of doing that
they would bring the jurors in in order
to save costs but they do will not do
that unless the judge decides that like
they would have to change the venue but
instead of physically changing it they
would bring jurors and but that
determination would be made in order for
them to bring the jurors in all right
we'll see how the judge decides then
thank you both and a win for the man at
the center of the famed serial podcast
as the baltimore city state's attorney
orders new forensic testing on evidence
in the case anand syed's case rose to
fame in 2014 when the podcast serial
broke listening records the
investigative series cast doubt on
syed's 2000 conviction for the murder of
his high school girlfriend 18 year old
heyman lee dna testing will now be
performed on lee's clothing as well as
her rape kit so far these items have not
been tested for dna syed has maintained
his innocence he has been behind bars
since his 1999 arrest
coming up on law on crime daily the
federal trial of accused sarah lawrence
calling sex cult leader our own adam
classfeld is inside the courtroom plus a
celibate cult leader ufo-based religion
and mass suicide we take a closer look
at the so-called heavens gate cult
[Music]
welcome back we're getting a closer look
at the notorious heavens gates cult
ahead of an abc's 2020 special on the
group's infamous leader heaven's gate
made headlines back in 1997 when 39
members were killed in a mass suicide
their bodies were found wearing matching
black jumpsuits nikes and armband saying
heaven's gate away team experts say the
group's leader marshall applewhite known
by followers as doe coerced them to
believe that a ufo spaceship was
trailing the coming haley bop comet and
that they must commit suicide to board
the aircraft
what kind of person joins a cult they
have rules about dressing rules about
sex how you brush your teeth how you use
the toilet they didn't have any free
will if you all choose to think that i'm
nuts then so be it you are all celibate
individuals
being castrated there's no sexuality he
castrates himself this is the guy that's
responsible for all these people
being dead
he was very deliberate about wanting to
go out with a bang something that
everybody would notice and they did
the heavens gate 2020 special is set to
air friday night at 9 00 p.m eastern on
abc it's a case that captured the
attention of the nation this week on
prime crime jesse webber takes a closer
look at the robert durst case in the
second episode of a two-part prime crime
special
hey there brian it's part two of our
continuing story on robert durst we
start with more of durst's bizarre 2015
interrogation and then we move into his
unforgettable trial in 2021 for the
murder of his friend susan berman there
are a lot of notable moments but none
more so than when he took the stand and
of course that cross-examination by
prosecutor john lewin was unlike
anything we've ever seen you testified
in galveston
that that's what happened correct
correct but today when i asked you about
the 24th
you said that you were already
in the apartment correct i thought you
were talking about the 17th well
well mr durst so a moment ago you said
you thought i was talking about the 28th
now you realize you got caught on a lie
and you're now trying to figure out what
can i do to square this i am not trying
to figure out any infection and yet it's
the conclusion to the robert durst saga
that many may not have predicted tune in
to law on crime
definitely an episode of cash you can
catch new episodes of prime crime every
friday at 5 30 and 10 30 p.m eastern
here on lawn crime network when we come
back we head to federal court in new
york as defendant lawrence ray stands
trial for his part in the sarah lawrence
college sex cult long crime network's
adam classville has the latest from the
courthouse
[Music]
welcome back to law and crime daily now
to a case in south carolina that of alec
murdoch the former lawyer who faces
dozens of criminal fraud charges a
motion was filed this week to hold
burdock in contempt of court days after
he gave up his claim to his murdered
wife's estate the suspended attorney is
charged with more than 70 crimes
stemming from allegedly stealing more
than eight and a half million dollars
from former clients other attorneys his
former law firm and the family of his
deceased housekeeper over the course of
more than a decade murdoch also faces
charges in relation to a scheme to
commit suicide and allegedly hiring a
hitman to kill him so his son buster
could collect a 10 million dollar life
insurance policy that came after his
wife maggie and other son were
mysteriously killed months earlier they
were found shot to death at the family's
1700 acre property no one has been
charged in their murders lawyers in
charge of murdoch's money say the
disgrace attorney gave up his claim to
his deceased wife's estate because his
son buster was named as a secondary
beneficiary they say that move shields
those assets from those he owes money to
which violates a ruling barring him from
transferring funds magnus state was
listed for sale last month for 3.9
million dollars
we head now to new york for the trial of
alleged sarah lawrence sex cult leader
lawrence wray as testimony continued
friday in federal court ray's alleged
crimes date back to 2010. that's when
prosecutors say he moved into his
daughter's on-campus housing at sarah
lawrence college they say he soon
assumed a role of father figure to her
friends prosecutors allege ray convinced
them to move into an apartment with him
on the upper east side of manhattan new
york over the next 10 years he allegedly
extorted millions of dollars from and
abused his victims forcing some into
prostitution race facing racketeering
and sex trafficking charges among others
the trial began with opening statements
on thursday followed by testimony from
one of rey's alleged victims rosario
santos who was also the ex-boyfriend of
rey's daughter talia
law encrimes adam
classfield is inside the courtroom
following this case closely he shares
details of that testimony from one of
rey's alleged victims
disturbing testimony that we heard for
the past two days comes from one of
rey's alleged victim santos rosario who
has testified about uh horrendous abuse
by larry ray against him and his sister
felicia rosario so today on the stand
we heard
and saw recordings both audio recordings
video recordings there was one recording
played in court
showing santos rosario the witness
slapping himself in the face repeatedly
in front of his sister at rey's alleged
request
to goad his sister to
behave to raise satisfaction the witness
identified a photograph of his face
after this all swollen up and he said
this was after an hour of slapping
himself at ray's instruction he said
that originally he
turned to rey as a
figure for inspiration and intensive ear
and
essentially grew to trust him but there
was a twisted turn in that relationship
that's just a sample of what's being
seen
and heard by these jurors as
this
uh case kicks off to a very disturbing
start
shocking and disturbing indeed dina he
held a knife to my genitals that's the
headline according to adam's twitter who
has been in the court this entire time
rey appears to be an absolute monster
from this testimony is this case all but
done with these facts or is there
something the defense can do
it means it's very hard to come back
from this because there's multiple
witnesses who are going to testify to
similar situations and they also have
video of him interacting with these
people and the testimony really helps
explain why they stayed with him and and
also helps
sympathize to what happened to them
of course we haven't gotten to this
defense case maybe they could pull
something out but this type of testimony
is very hard to come back from yeah i
mean let's talk about the testimony
terry how does the testimony of this
ex-boyfriend uh ray's daughter kind of
impact the jury in a case like this
you know i think this jury is thinking
what kind of monster is this defendant
it is the most bizarre story i think
i've ever heard we know that santos
rosario dated rey's daughter so they put
him on the stand first because that is
really something that the jury is going
to look at and say how could you have
abused him he's your daughter's
boyfriend i don't understand how you
could do these things to anyone but i
think it was very impactful
yeah i mean his relationship to the
family is definitely something to be
strong for the prosecution thank you
both and of course thank you for joining
us here law and crime daily we'll see
you next time as we discuss justice in
america
[Music]
you